recently we saw millions of women
marching in various cities around the
world after the election of Donald Trump
and his inauguration we have seen sort
of talk about rolling back women's
access to contraception in the u.s.
women's access to family planning
clinics worldwide that take us aid money
that will no longer be able to give
advice on abortion access to family
planning etc are you worried at all that
we're in a climate right now where these
type of initiatives this type of work
could be threatened not just by your
work but by other foundations other
advocacy groups other initiatives that
are doing similar work well I'm
personally concerned about the Mexico
City policy that's put back on and
particularly we'll see what happens of
it but you know I believe in universal
access I'm very open about that
universal access to contraceptives but
potentially the way this policy is being
talked about this time which we've never
had before in the history of the United
States the way they're talking about
potentially implementing where you would
actually affect clinics that also give
out hiv/aids drugs tuberculosis drugs
malaria drugs but we have the the the
u.s. gives to something called the
Global Fund which is for AIDS
tuberculosis and malaria 20 million
people are alive because of that fund so
when I go out around the developing
world and I visit these very small
clinics that the US and the UK and
France and Germany have all helped set
up and to think about they won't be
there in a community anymore that a
person won't be able to go get their HIV
AIDS drugs we believe in giving people
in the United States HIV AIDS drug but
because of the way we're gonna implement
a policy all of a sudden the whole
clinic is going to be shut down wow that
doesn't sound to me like the American
people we are and the value we have for
life we've chosen as as a country to
give money to this fund but now we're
gonna we might we might put all of that
work at risk that that just doesn't make
sense to me and when I think about our
values as Americans when I think about
what we care
about or the dignity of life we care
about that but we also care about peace
and security and if we want peace and
security in the United States making
these investments in the developing
world is what allows people to stay
where they are right they want a better
life in their own community so there's
also a peace and security aspect to do
it to me that makes absolutely no sense
in that there's been a backlash against
kind of international investment
international aid in some corners not
just the US and the UK as well you just
describe it as you know fundamental to
what we believe as Americans as values
do you think they understand that when
you say that that the trade-off for this
type of policy is literally not giving
people access to life-saving drugs what
could be done to make that advocacy more
clear will you be even more front and
public about this well I think you're
gonna hear Bill and I in through the in
your letter we're trying to speak the
truth about what we see you know through
all the work we do all year long we've
done for over 15 years now all the
changes in the developing world and no
in the u.s. less than 1% of Americans
know that poverty has been cut in half
in less 25 years so it's it's something
we're trying to get the messages out
about so that people understand that
these investments that we make that we
ask our government to make are making a
profound difference in the developing
world and you know I would say to people
if you care about these issues if you
care about peace and security in the
world call your senator and say I care
about these four and $8 continuing to be
spent in the same way they have been in
the past